hey Mon hey we have a bunch of messages
and that's nice Hanna quit while you
were gone I guess she memo to file some
complaints she had about being a working
mother and so you might also have to be
deposed blah blah blah blah relax just
relax okay I'll get to all of it later
aren't you going to ask me how to make
it was sad how much maybe not so good it
sandals Jamaica when somebody says hey
Mon everybody's is a mom back Oh Michael
I'm glad you're here Stanley you know
what it is really good to see you too
my bonus check was a hundred dollars
less than you promised okay well payroll
is in charge of all of that he said I
should talk to you well I am just
getting settled in so I'm gonna I am NOT
doing a lick more work until I get my
full bonus show you who are not as much
fun as your Jamaican broad does mine
we can't believer at Hogwarts
no that's Buckingham Palace Hogwarts is
fictional do you know that it's
important to me that you know that okay
guys we are going to be sightseeing
today Andy and Ben are gonna go to their
meeting and then we can go back to the
hotel for lunch and I will spend the day
getting to know London's history history
began on July 4th 1776 everything before
that was a mistake
Diane suggested we tag along to London
for a honeymoon I agreed because my love
for her Trump's my hatred for Europe
then she hit a phase of morning sickness
that knocked her for a loop and decided
to stay home but she insisted I go and
take pictures for her all of this could
have been avoided if we'd followed my
plan for a honeymoon a steak dinner
a glass of Lagavulin whiskey then
vigorous lovemaking for two hours and
were both asleep by 8:30 hello everybody
in my hands I hold the driving
directions to this year's detectives
only getaway give it a cool name Jake
all right detectives only getaway do G
dog dog party dog party 15 whoo foo foo
big shout-out to Charles Boyle for
hosting us at his beach house this year
yeah you should really think my ex-wife
we split it in the divorce I get it for
December through February winter b-house
whoa
yes gnarly catching on as always there
will be no spouses no bosses no work no
bedtimes within reason
all right Santiago's feeling rowdy who
else is feeling it I can't wait this
weekend I am vacation Terry no kids no
responsibilities I'm just a balloon
floating in the great blue sky and I am
untethered and just to clarify how
untethered is vacation Terry from his
wife very tether all right anyone else
have questions Hitchcock Scully you've
been weirdly silent we don't want to say
anything that would get us uninvited
smort all right get pump people dog
party 15
[Applause]
two bottles of vodka is this gonna be
the weekend we finally meet six-drink
amy
six-drink amy what does that mean it's
the pinnacle of the Santiago drunkenness
scale one drink aim is a little Spacey
wait what two drinks loud Amy you want
to get a cab three drinks Amy dance
pants or drink Amy is a bit of a pervert
hey check it out and five-drink amy is
weirdly confident let's do this little
man but I've never seen six-drink amy
maybe she's the one I could actually be
friends with aka my sasquatch hey dude
just got back from Jamaica yeah that
sounds amazing but you know what the
lady Jan Levinson wanted to go to
Montego Bay well I'm looking at a photo
right now and I'm telling you it could
be in Maxim they wouldn't give you a
subscription to Maxim Oh No okay well
check this out I'm sending you some
email you got it no check it again hit
refresh yeah okay wait a second I sent
it to you at Packer at dunder-mifflin
dot-com packaging at Dunder Mifflin oh
wait I just got it from somebody else
Wow how do I get you out of this picture
Jerell hey hi where's Darryl in the
office hey hey man how's it going all
right
it's not Mike that's great okay um so
did you get an email from me yeah okay
well that was supposed to go to Packer
not packaging mm-hmm did you already
forward it to a whole bunch of people
uh-huh okay um well did you get the
second email that I sent explaining the
first email was a mistake and that you
should delete it
yep and he said that I'll see everyone
Mike I'm very busy down here so I long
for a day when women in government will
simply be seen as people in government
but until then I will work to make
Pawnee my wonderful hometown as good as
it can be what do you think I think you
should lose the first line and the last
line and all of the other lines and
instead just walk up to the mic and meow
really loudly for eight minutes okay
this trip is amazing but I miss Pawnee
you know I want to know what's happening
there one little news blast wouldn't
hurt welcome to the final word with perd
miss Pinewood
there is a thing you are doing and that
thing is you are leading a recall vote
against Councilwoman Knope and you say
you have new shocking allegations about
her what what now bird I take no
pleasure in reporting this but it must
come to light we are here trying to make
Pawnee better and where is Leslie Knope
she's gallivanting around Europe like
some kind of European you know it's
really tough to how do they get the
picture so but I just Facebook
apparently she can't be bothered to stay
here in Pawnee not when there's Europe
to gallivant around in well we conducted
up heard polled and asked this question
do you think Leslie Knope should be in
England do you not think that or do you
not think that 48% said she should not
be in Europe 17% say it's okay and 35%
said they were confused by the way the
question
was posed oh my god Peralta I thought
you already left yeah closed a couple of
cases and had to finish up the paperwork
also I wanted to thank you again for
giving us this half day yes of course I
understand how important these
extravaganzas are I'm sure you'll have a
hoot oh yeah
although I'm sure our hoots pale in
comparison to the hoots that you had
back in the day I bet things got Supes
hoots actually I wasn't privy to those
events as a gay black detective I was
excluded from most social gatherings you
guys off to blazing golf yeah caddie no
I do not
yeah golf sucks I know that wasn't the
point of your story those guys were
jerks yes but I do Envy the camaraderie
they shared I've always wanted the Josh
arrived with my peers so you've never
joshed around with anyone never but go
have fun with the squad really just Rob
for me welcome to chateau Royale Eleanor
told me to keep the place clean but I
don't care mommy's out of town and we're
gonna party you call your ex-wife mommy
not consciously this will do just fine
you brought pineapple well the fanny was
deep I am prepared for any vacation
situations I've got a bottle opener
sunscreen inflatable neck pillow wait
are we having undue tight Gina you ready
to party or why oh don't mind if I uh uh
Wow
you're two shots behind linetti what up
party people you know how I'm always
saying it ain't a real party till your
boss shows up unexpectedly well it's a
party what are you talking about
hello party people we're also told me to
say that yeah I did
ain't no party like a captain whole
party cuz the captain whole party is a
total surprise to everyone okay
everybody have their towels and
swimsuits
we've been an hour and a half I suggest
that you all go potty now and then we
will be congregating on the partay bus
oh I'm excited today is beach day
Michael is taking the whole office to
the beach so I'm wearing my bathing suit
underneath my shirt oh yeah packed in my
purse
you